marijuana decriminalization is coming to
New Hampshire decriminalization not
legalization
this is HB 640 it's been signed into law
by New Hampshire Governor Chris Sununu
it will not take effect for 60 days not
everybody realizing that and it will
make New Hampshire the 22nd state to
decriminalize marijuana now being
decriminalization rather than
legalization it's going to eliminate
jail time as a possibility for simple
marijuana possession for personal use
it'll make it a ticket sort of like a
speeding ticket and if you have up to
three quarters of an ounce of marijuana
you will no longer be potentially
punished by up to the year in prison and
$2,000 fine that you currently are
instead it will be a civil violation
punishable by a hundred dollar fine for
your first or second offense and a $300
fine for a third offense within the
first three within three years of the
first offense this is good right this is
obviously good it's still crazy to me
the idea that you would start paying
hundred and two hundred dollar tickets
for having three quarters of an ounce of
marijuana right like I think because of
the status quo in this country we've
been sort of conditioned to say oh if
you can no longer go to jail that's a
really big thing it's still not that
having three quarters of an ounce of a
plant might put you in jail I'm sorry
would get you a two hundred dollar
ticket
especially when the vast majority of
people in New Hampshire agree with
legalization agree with
decriminalization yeah and you know I
think what's telling to here is that New
Hampshire has been hit hard by the
opiate epidemic yes I am so I think
there's two natural dots that can come
up come out of that when you talk about
marijuana some people may think well we
should take this hard stance against all
drugs stop things that could potentially
be a gateway into opiates like marijuana
would be to her but then there's other
people who are realizing that you're
putting those two things in the same
group when they're not one in the same
and if you have a more sensible
marijuana policy you won't have people
going into the black-market in pursuit
of other drugs and in fact we've seen
that in places where marijuana has been
legalized you see a decrease in
opioid-related overdoses and
from from a criminal justice so opiate
act aspect is big in New Hampshire
criminal justice aspect is big as well
in 2012 almost 3,000 people were
arrested in New Hampshire for simple
possession the type of possession that
now would no longer potentially put you
in jail so that's a really good thing
the next step is full legal eagle
ization and it's kind of funny that you
know New Hampshire's motto is live free
or die very very libertarian State
they've got all these movements about
getting people to move up there for all
the freedom and liberty they're the last
state in New England to decriminalize
marijuana and part of this if you don't
live in New England you might not
realize New England is this weird mix of
super progressive but also more
traditionally conservative in the sense
of like the Kennedys you know the
Kennedys rather than Bernie is the way I
think about it and there's a lot of
these strange outdated blue laws about
when you can buy alcohol there's no
happy hour in Massachusetts you can't
reduce the price of alcohol it did start
as a puritanical society that's exactly
right that's exactly right and people in
other parts of the country might not get
that there is still significant
opposition to marijuana legalization in
many enclaves of different New England
states and obviously in many other
states as well where it's just flat out
like oh no no decriminalization no we
want stricter penalties for people
caught with marijuana you have to
understand that it's live free or die
when it comes to issues that
conservatives all support so for example
you know the right to bear arms right
when I talk we talk about like marijuana
or abortion they're up for that more of
a conversation that they want to have
there let's not let's not go too crazy
with this freedom and liberty stuff
might might not be good yeah I mean did
we we increasingly do have at minimum
two countries here in the United States
I talked about my experience recently
visiting Pensacola Florida which is to
call it the deep south I think is the
most accurate way to say it and day to
day the similarities between someone's
environment in Massachusetts and in in
the panhandle of Florida is very
different we speak the same language we
sort of have the same president although
I don't know that everyone would even
agree about that but it's a very very
different situation and I think that
when we we see a continued divergence on
drug laws and in many other areas of the
law the
contrast between the multiple united
states States's of america is going to
become much more noticeable let's take a
break
tremendous program today and big
breaking news actually to tell you about
also saving it for the end of the show
next today's program is made possible in
part by tag adapt the hosting specialist
they host websites for everybody from
bloggers to businesses to financial
traders you can get virtual dedicated
and private server solutions cloud
server solutions custom server solutions
whatever is right for your project or
business is available at taga deb and
with a growing number of people
increasingly interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is offering our viewers and
listeners a twenty british pound free
credit when you sign up to give you a
chance to try out their cloud server
solution this is a limited availability
offer first-come first-served for
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS and use the discount code TV
PS 20 during your account registration
twenty British pounds roughly twenty
three twenty four US dollars once again
check it out signup tag adapt calm /td
PS the discount code is TD PS 20